en este vídeo vamos a hablar sobre la
derivada con respecto a x del logaritmo
natural de x y les diré cuál es el
resultado es igual a 1 entre x veremos
la demostración de esto en un vídeo
futuro ya que es un poco complicado por
eso en este vídeo vamos a suponer que
esto es verdadero aquí tenemos la
gráfica de e igual al logaritmo natural
de x y para estar más cómodos con este
enunciado vamos a tratar de aproximar la
pendiente de la recta tangente en varios
puntos como será la pendiente en el
punto donde x es igual a 1 en este punto
parece que la pendiente es muy cercana a
1 lo que es consistente con este
enunciado cuando x es igual a 11 entre 1
es 1 que coincide con lo que vemos aquí
que pasa cuando x es igual a 2 en este
punto es el logaritmo natural de 2 pero
nos interesa la pendiente de la recta
tangente en este punto y parece que es
cercana a un medio nuevamente esto es 1
/ x 1 / 2 es un medio sigamos haciendo
esto cuando x es igual a 4 este punto es
4 coma
a ritmo natural de 4 pero la pendiente
de la recta tangente aquí parece que es
un cuarto y esto es igual a 1 entre 4
también podemos ver valores menores a 1
cuando x es igual a un medio 1 entre un
medio es 2 por lo que la pendiente de la
recta tangente en este punto debería ser
igual a 2 vamos a dibujarlo con otro
color aquí parece que efectivamente la
pendiente es igual a 2 en resumen para
calcular la derivada con respecto a x
del logaritmo natural de x vamos a tener
que es igual a 1 entre x y espero que
puedan ver que en la gráfica esto tiene
sentido demostraremos esto en un futuro
vídeo y con esto terminamos